l'été 2022 a été le plus chaud jamais
enregistré en europe avec comme
conséquence plus de 60 000 décès
attribuables à la chaleur dont une vague
particulièrement intense fin juillet
l'Italie enregistre le plus grand nombre
de décès devant l'Espagne l'Allemagne et
la France la France arrive en quatrième
position avec autour de 5000 DC lié à la
chaleur mais en termes relatif
c'est-à-dire le nombre de décès par
millions d'habitants le chiffre est bien
inférieur à la moyenne européenne
quand la glace est rompue pour de bon
la France a connu un réchauffement
rapide de son climat
les conséquences du dérèglement
climatique se font sentir au Japon nous
vous parlions hier de ces inondations le
pays en est victime au moins 5 personnes
sont mortes dans le Sud-Ouest et le
bilan pourrait alourdir des milliers
d'habitants ont dû être évacués les
pluies diluviennes ont fait sortir les
rivières de leur lit et provoquer des
glissements de terrain
il se représente mal ce qu'une poignée
de degrés peut bien changer mais c'est
sans compter sur le pouvoir de l'eau en
Afrique du Sud c'est la neige qui a
surpris les habitants de Johannesburg
bien sûr de ce côté-là de l'hémisphère
c'est l'hiver mais un tel phénomène est
tout de même suffisamment rare pour être
signalé autre mari est prof aussi comme
vous pas du tout il fait quoi et
travaille dans une centrale nucléaire
et vous voulez sauver la planète vous
avez dit au début moi oui ok vous êtes
rencontré comment
dans ce restaurant Le four réchauffé à
350 degrés le personnel a reçu des
consignes il faut s'hydrater très
régulièrement
prendre l'eau dès qu'on peut même nos
responsables il nous rappelle souvent de
boire on a pas le choix de façon sinon
après la tête qui tourne tout ça enfin
faut s'hydrater comme il faut quand on a
de la bonne chaleur
ça fait presque 7 ans que je fais ce
travail
et tu as quel âge
j'ai 14 ans
j'ai commencé à 6 ans
c'est un travail très pénible
et on gagne pas beaucoup
je continue d'aller à l'école mais quand
il n'y a pas classe je reviens
travailler ici
je les ai entendus
[Applaudissements]
sur scène le rappeur Alkpote promet une
offrande au public belge le français qui
ne cache pas être un grand consommateur
de cannabis s'annonce alors une
distribution gratuite la suite paraît
surréaliste deux hommes jettent des
joints par centaines dans la foule la
vidéo de la scène a explosé sur les
réseaux sociaux et comme le rapporte le
média belge Sudinfo la police belge a
ouvert une enquête sur la base de ces
images où l'on entend clairement le
rappeur galvaniser son public
rassasiez-vous une pluie pour vous de
joie et de bonheur de la part de
l'empereur c'est le nom de son dernier
album et puis ici passer la tradition
c'est du quartier les sabots et regardez
ça sert à se réveiller le matin voilà
vous savez tout
en Belgique il est interdit de vendre ou
de donner des stupéfiants c'est même un
délit passible de 50 prisons et 2500
euros d'amende tout comme le fait
d'inciter à la consommation de cannabis
l'enquête ne fait que débuter encore
faudra-t-il prouver que derrière le ha
il y a bien trafic de stupéfiants et que
les joints lancés depuis la scène sont
bien chargés en cannabis 50 burgers 150
yakitoris et plus de 800 mille abonnés
sur Youtube Alan fou de challenge s'est
fait connaître en relevant des défis
alimentaires le dernier en date 5
gigatacos 15 kg de viande impossible
pour de nombreux internautes qui
remettent en cause la véracité de la
vidéo l'honneur devait être rétabli en
direct sur twitch mais au bout d'un
tacos et demi bon vous voulez savoir je
vais arrêter là alors on a été dit que
là on a été validé il met unique
c'est-à-dire une douane
immense déception sur les réseaux
d'autant qu'à l'âne a avoué avoir truqué
au moins une autre vidéo
un blouson de cuir noir avec un aime le
sur le dos ça monte
je mets la pire heure dans toute la
question c'était imprimé parce que je
trouvais que les dessins il était beau
tu m'as imprimé
parce que le dessin était beau c'est à
dire que c'est pas un dessin
c'est une photo c'est une photocopie
d'une photo
d'accord
c'est on en est à ce stade là c'est à
dire que tu t'es dit bon je vais y aller
je vais faire une photocopie d'une photo
en plus je la reconnais très bien cette
photo c'est moi